in a Polish Auditorium Ukrainian
refugees watch a film comparing the
World War II destruction of Warsaw with
last year's Russian bombardment of
mariopol
Warsaw was rebuilt and Rose shiny and
new From the Ashes
so too the thinking goes will Ukraine's
devastated cities like Mario Paul
on a guided tour of Warsaw later where
traces of the war still remain some feel
only faint hope
we had will never be the same it'll be
different we cannot know how but the
life we had there will never return that
life was stolen from us
hope is a common ingredient in the lives
of Ukrainian refugees scattered the
world over a large proportion benefiting
from the generosity of neighboring
Poland but the warmth and safety of
sponsored accommodation is no barrier to
pain
March 20th was a more or less quiet day
so we left the basement and I remember
it was my daughter's birthday
nor to the realization that what began
as a temporary relocation could last
much longer
and while there are those returning to
safer parts of Ukraine especially as
winter lifts many continue to flee the
fighting in the south and east train
loads of newcomers arrive on Poland's
eastern border almost every day
we sold every
just to have money to come across you
sold all your belongings yeah
even books
it was too hard
and here only my mom
since the War Began more than 8 million
people of disembarked trains like this
one from Ukraine many of them going on
to settle in countries all over the
world while Poland alone has taken in
around one and a half million and this
country's generosity now being sorely
tested as the war goes on
in recent years Poland has become
infamous for its unwelcoming attitude to
migrants from Africa and the Middle East
trying to cross the border from Belarus
not so those from Ukraine but while the
country spends billions of dollars
supporting them and as the cost of
living soars the hope that they'll one
day be able to leave Poland is not felt
by the ukrainians alone
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera premish Poland